definitely felt like my old building it
was for japanese families oh yeah
well you were living in an area that was
very like oh you're not not exactly like
gaijin friendly
we all because we all lived five minutes
away from each other yeah back in the
day and i lived even further out than
you guys yeah i definitely lived with
like all like the um and in a relatively
older building as well oh yeah it was
super old yeah and uh it was definitely
a family building as well i don't know
and i didn't see anyone else there who
looked even remotely my age yeah yeah uh
they were nice though i never really had
any problems
i got a i got a noise complaint but i
expected as much yeah well i mean if
you're shouting at [ __ ] too late
sorry it's one of those things
when i first moved in i would literally
walk around my own apartment like metal
gear solid like i was so because i'd
heard nightmare scenarios about noise
where i was just tiptoeing around my
apartment like at night because i
genuinely thought if i just walked at a
normal brisk pace yeah i would get like
shouted out
but you know the months go on and you
start to realize you know okay okay i
guess i can't help the clapping of my
ass cheeks being so loud
i'm so dummy thick yeah it's like tommy
thinking you know then one time i had
friends over who stayed over till five
and i never got a noise complaint and
then i was like oh okay and then you
slowly get more comfortable you test the
limit yeah because you know
and then maybe something happened where
all right there's a deadline i have to
record this thing it's 2 a.m and they
need it right now yeah okay well i guess
i'll do it i'll just scream one line
then i'll do it and then also i had to
record voice lines one time i distinctly
remember were full-on shouting yeah but
this was like mid-day yeah but it was to
the point where i was this is shouting
so loud and so aggressively that i i
would totally understand if the police
were called right in any scenario it
sounded like a murder was happening
literally even a murderer wouldn't have
done it with such conviction the way i
did so i was i did that and that
definitely made me more confident so it
was one of those things where i just
built up and then i started streaming
and i started streaming later yeah and
later and later and then i started
streaming louder and louder and then
eventually i got a noise complaint yeah
which was totally because i think it was
one where i was totally screaming at 4am
which i totally understood i just
assumed the people below me because this
was a four bedroom
i just assumed they were sleeping in a
totally different room and they were so
old that they nothing would wake them up
i was hoping that they were that kind of
old people where they were they were not
getting up for anything yeah that's the
thing sometimes like you get lucky
because like the the room that if you
especially if you have multiple rooms
the room that you scream the loudest
yeah is nowhere near where the person
downstairs is sleeping yeah it's it's
always it's mostly like where is the
bedroom located yeah and am i making a
lot of noise where their bedroom is
located because anywhere else i feel
like it's the more understanding about
it but it's always the bedroom yeah and
i think like i really lucked out with
the apartment i had before because i've
never got a noise complaint and i'm very
lucky i don't know how you yeah i feel
like i definitely should like i [ __ ]
limit test that thing i i i had parties
at your house
yeah
we've had very loud parties at 5 00 a.m
um on a saturday so if we weren't being
completed
it doesn't matter to the old people in
japan in japan that is that is not uh
that is that is not acceptable anywhere
but uh it's uh yeah i [ __ ] limit
broke that [ __ ] and i didn't get a noise
complaint and i'm like very very
surprised saturday's it it doesn't
matter what day of the week it is to an
old person like because like the cops
aren't going to be like all right we got
a noise complaining you'd be like
oh saturday license to party
[Music]
have a nice day i just i just feel like
i i feel like a locked up because i feel
like i had neighbors who had like a
mutual understanding because i feel like
i've had the only neighbor i can i that
i've know of of anyone living in japan
that was like really [ __ ] noisy yeah
um like they would have arguments all
the [ __ ] time it wasn't just like a
japanese argument it was full-on
shouting sometimes it was the most
unjapanese japanese argument i've ever
heard right and i'm just like
if if you if you make noise then you
know i'm going to make noise as well
i'm making you want to understand yeah
mutual understanding that's that's it's
a symbiotic
relationship
i was always very you know even if i
wasn't making noise i would be if if
they're having a party once a month yeah
so be it yeah exactly it's once a month
i can live with that it's not like i
have like uh
i don't know like a bonsai tree that's
sensitive to noise or something in my
apartment that shits itself here's two
decibels you know what i mean like i'm
yeah i think it's okay yeah yeah that's
why i wouldn't really call the cops but
japanese people have no chill with that
and they just immediately call the cops
well no because to them it's like why
are you being so loud at home when you
could just go to an izakaya or go out in
town and have fun and i'm like i would
if everything doesn't close at 8pm and
alcohol can't be served
yeah one of the things that's been so
taking so long in my new place is that
my office i've actually like gone
through the whole effort of like trying
to sound treat it to the best of my
ability right as much as you can because
the best way to sound
proof a room is to do it while they're
building the goddamn room yeah um you
know but i've had to do it in post yeah
yeah and uh it's been a nightmare so
i've had to put like two layers of stuff
on my wall and then i still haven't done
it all yet um so like two layers of
fabric um that i've attached to the wall
and then i'm doing the third which is
the like sound foam yeah because you
know youtubers just put like four pieces
and they're like it's soundproof my room
and it's like that is not even remotely
soundproof i like the i like the rooms
where it's like one piece over here and
another piece over here and it's just
like it's just one piece behind where
they're sitting yeah like my job here is
my lumber looks super weird right now
because it's just all like every single
wall is like a black plastic rubber yeah
but it works it's like you can't really
hear me immediately the echo is gone
it's yeah and so i i put uh i put a
layer of the uh
the rubber stuff down as well and then i
put noise reducing carpet on top of it
so like you can jump in my room
neighbors ain't gonna hear [ __ ]
downstairs yeah i i actually just
finished like that in my office as well
like finally yes i i was talking about
joey what i was doing and jay was like
that sounds like a good idea yeah so i
decided to do that in my room because my
my room was like super [ __ ] accurate
because i have like wooden floors all
right so immediately
immediately once i put up before i even
started putting up the sound foam
immediately with the carpet it's like
eighty percent of the execution yeah
every single wall you do makes it it
gets better results yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's it's not since i moved to japan
that i'm just like man carpets are good
i miss carpets yeah cause like we had
carpets in england like you you didn't
have a like you didn't have a house you
never had a house in england that had
wooden floors right because it's not
good for noise are not noise like
uh heat insulation no really no living
room is wooden but upstairs was carpet
yeah yeah so the house was like halfway
in like your rooms you'd have carpet
yeah i didn't know how much i missed
that until i moved to asia where
everything here is wooden floors well we
had like fitted carpet in in europe i
think where like they come in and they
especially like
get the right size and they fit it all
yeah yeah but in japan they always use
these the square like just pick up and
go okay yeah the post carpet yeah they
just they in japan like a lot of the
carpets are just like you'll see them
everywhere they're just like these like
cubes
yeah they're everywhere like they're
just like squares you plunk them down
and then you just cut them around the
edges so i had to like hand cut it to my
room it looks really [ __ ] good but i
spent like a whole [ __ ] day doing it
yeah i did too because my room's not
square yeah it's like it's like weird
[ __ ] shapes i'm like oh and cutting
the corners and stuff yeah so like it
looks good from a distance but when you
get down on the floor you see how much
of a [ __ ] joy
but that shit's hard man it's hard i'm
very proud of it i've been diying for
like two days yes but it looks great it
looks amazing and when everything's set
up it should be good yeah that'll be me
in like two months yeah i think because
we're i think i'm the last one to move
out
i'm planning to have a whole wall of
just jojo posters oh no that'll be like
did you have that in your old place no
no literally because before you could
see the walls i was gonna make it like
oh like like
literally like
90 of the wall is your jojo posters
isn't it already
no but like they had gaps they had gaps
i don't want guests i want it to be
literally it's like
myself it's made out of jojo that's the
warning the wall is joe's joke the floor
is jojo
how good of a shot would it be it's like
just behind me it's literally just jojo
that's so bad
the wall is just
so like the way i attached it to the
wall was like i wasn't sure if it would
it would like be able to hold the
posters because this this rubber stuff
that i got to prevent sound is is
[ __ ] heavy yeah right you poured a
roll as well right yeah it is like it's
it's uh what is it
10 meters
it's a 10 meter roll
by like one meter wide i think one meter
wide 10 meters long and it's 20
kilograms and it is so [ __ ] heavy
yeah put that on your wall yeah exactly
right how
with great difficulty
and so i was concerned i was like the
way i attached it i was like i wonder if
it will stay if i then put posters on it
so before i left for my trip i attached
the posters and i was like hopefully
when i come back my wall will be intact
and it luckily it's intact yeah should
be fine but the poster frames i have are
extremely light they're like the
lightest poster oh yeah you should be
all right yeah should be should be fine
hopefully be really awkward if i'm
streaming one day and my whole world
[ __ ] comes down i feel like the big
test is going to be in summer right or
next summer i'm just going to leave my
ac on because yeah yeah i'm not risking
it really all the time that's what i did
in my in my current place because
you know the electricity bill right if
you have i had like what like 20 grand
of computer equipment in my room and
filming equipment the ac bill to have it
running all all the time is what like
maybe an extra 200 300 bucks for the
whole summer well yeah it depends on how
long you have it on for i guess so for
the summer period just leave it on yeah
i'll pay that much just to have my
equipment be fine yeah humidity [ __ ]
your microphones and cameras and pc
equipment i i i would rather just have
the whole room ac20 yeah i'm thinking to
invest in a dehumidifier just to put
around humidifier yeah yeah oh i have a
dc meter
as like a southeast asian i'm just like
i'm like part of my part of my soul is
dying yeah ac is on twenty four seven
man ac on dehumidify there's a setting
for dehumidifier yeah that's true so i
leave it okay okay okay what happens if
the when the ac inevitably breaks it's
an it's a good ac it's not braking
didn't your ac brake
yeah one of the other ac is broken but
yeah so what's to say won't happen in
your room the other one for two years
was fine i'll deal with it when it
breaks because it'll be down for like
three days at most it's fine right
because because like i'm because like i
grew up with like i grew up with my
parents beating into me that i was just
like look the world could be on [ __ ]
fire right now but you're not turning on
that ac unless you like really or
something really needed to be like
connor's wasting so much electricity
you're not in the room and i'm like
you know i'm saving saving money yeah
he's saving the equipment he's saving
the equipment